GM once designed a car
that went 400 miles on a single strip of bacon
that car was never released
because it's a waste of bacon
celery once challenged bacon to a duel
that's why celery has no flavor.
the song brown eyed girl was about bacon
it's just a complicated metaphor, numbnuts!
bacon was invented by... bacon
I just blew your f***** mind!
That liquid that surrounds beacon in the skillet
That's not grease, that's just the skillet crying tears of joy.
every word you say has a silent bacon in it
You fart blaster
bacon doesn't clog your arteries, just reinforces them.
they used to play rocks, paper, scissors, bacon. But they took out bacon, because bacon always wins
The average american eats one hundred pieces of bacon a year
that includes vegetarians and babies.
that means even the average vegetarian baby eats one hundred pieces of bacon a year
that's science, bitch.
the only reason to put bacon in a salad is
to remind all of the vegetables that they suck
The higgs boson gets its flavor by passing through a field of bacon.
you freak nerd.
in crisis situations, bacon has been known to fry itself.
just because it can, Dickweed
the number one cause of divorce is something about bacon.
bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon bacon, bacon
bacon
you bong nugget.
you little turd temple
you sack dingle.
You dirty nipple bag